hello everyone I know you're all eagerly
awaiting to expand your vast knowledge
of the 1959 candidates tournament so
let's just dive straight into it here we
have a very nice game between Icelandic
grandmasters ridicolous on and Bobby
Fischer
now the itical of Sun became a very
strong player very quickly he's the
first known result that got him like
famous in the international scene was
shared first place with Viktor Korchnoi
in the 1955 Hastings tournament and
already in 1958 he won't shared 56 place
in the intra zonal tournament of Porto
ROG so he immediately qualified for the
candidates of 1959 and by doing so he
got his Grandmaster title and I believe
a human Fischer both got the Grandmaster
title in 1958 for those of you who are
maybe having problems with the name
Porto rose you might have heard of it by
the name of Port of roses so this is a
game by them and it's a very interesting
because all of Sun will use Fisher's own
weapon against him Fisher will go for
the Sicilian and all of them will go for
the Bishop to c4 line and for those of
you who like playing this is Cillian and
like playing against this is Selena I
think you'll really enjoy this game so
let's check it out we have E for buy all
of some c5 the Sicilian defense Knight
to f3 d6 and d4 and we have C captures
on d4 Knight captures on d4 Knight to f6
and Knight to c3 a6 now so the knight of
variation is on the board and now Bishop
to c4 here he employs the Fischer weapon
against Fischer himself but before I
forget I did try to find a photo of the
two of them playing in this tournament I
wasn't successful but after searching
some dark corners of the internet I was
able to find an even better photo so
here it is this is a photo of all the
participants of the 1959 candidates
tournament so it's it's not a very high
quality photo but still it's you know
you definitely want to have this photo I
will put a link in the description below
so you can you know use it for whatever
you want me we want to print it and put
it you know on your fridge or something
here we have Bobby Fischer there hitting
his in his jumper or is it maybe a
sweater and next to him on the right is
very recall of some and all the other
participants as well so a very nice
photo and here we have E 6 so the
Scheveningen variation a 3 so this is a
this is where all of some uses a
different approach she doesn't go for
Fischer's Bishop to b3 but instead he
plays 83 and he will safely target the
bishop away - 8 - Bishop to e7 now we
have castles castles and Bishop 2a 2b 5
we had f4 Bishop to b7 attacking that
efore pawn and now f5 and here the only
good move for black is actually to push
a 5 which Bobby does so e 5 we have a
nice D 2 e 2 and now all of some has the
idea of playing Knight 2 G 3 Bishop to
g5 and after the bishop comes to g5
playing Knight to h5 to really pile up
on that f6 Knight salt Knight B to d7
we have Knight the g3 now look the c8
and Bishop to g5 and this is the
critical moment of the game although in
the game it will not actually be a
critical moment but I will get back to
this in the game here a Fischer played
knife to b6 and here
Knight to h5 was played and only now
Fischer played rook captures on c3 so
this is a pretty standard exchange
sacrifice when you play the Sicilian yo
sometimes you grab that knight on c3 -
we can be for pawn and you will get some
counter play for the exchange so B
captures on c3 was played now Knight
captures on h5 Bishop captures Queen
captures and now Queen captures on h5
and here Bishop captures on e4 so
grabbing the d4 pawn and now Fischer has
a very nice Center and those see pawns
are very weak but the problem is it was
in this position actually when Bishop to
g5 was played like I said and now you've
seen that Bishop passed Fischer played
nice to b6
instead he should have immediately
played Knight captures on
see to rock a transitory without going
night to be six first and allowing night
to age five
because now when you immediately play
rookie actress on c3 now after be
captures on c3 now you play tonight
captors on e4 and after Bishop captures
Queen captures Knight captures Bishop
captures now you have this position on
the board instead of the position that
actually happened in the game because in
this position Fischer has a knight on b7
ready to jump to f6 and whites queen is
an be one but in the game in the
position that actually happened after
this Bishop captures on e4 Fischer's
Knight is some b6 very far away from the
f6 square and all of Sons queen is
already on h5
fortunately for Fischer also didn't
really take advantage of this in this
position also played Queen to g4 with
the idea of pushing f6 and winning the
game immediately when instead he should
have pushed f6 immediately so after G
captures on f6 now he has this Queen to
h4 move attacking the f6 pawn and the
bishop on e4
so after d5 defending the bishop now
Queen captures on f6 attacking the Queen
and the night so after Queen captures
rook captures again you're attacking the
knight and da6 born and after rook to be
eight rook a comes to f1 you double up
on the F file and here black doesn't
really have compensation for the
exchange but fortunately for Fischer all
of some didn't punish this immediately
would have sex he played Queen to g4 he
prepared the f6 move now Fischer plays
d5 we have f6 and now Queen the c5 check
King to h1 and now g6 we have rook 81
and here Fischer played rook to e8 now
here I measure Fischer missed a very
nice opportunity again in the game to
actually grab this pawn and completely
share those pawns and then he could
probably take advantage of this very
nice Center but he missed that he won't
be in trouble because he you you have to
be careful White has this nice f6 pawn
and there's always the threat of Queen
to g5 Queen to h6 and Queen to g7
checkmate but fortunately this
doesn't work in this position because
after Queen captures on c3 now Queen to
g5 is met with Knight to d7 and now if
you continue with your plan Queen h6 now
you simply get Knight captures on f6 and
white is completely shattered black is
now completely winning this game you
can't grab the rope the the knight of
course because Queen captures any one
will lead to checkmate but okay after
rook a to e1 Fischer played rook to e8
defending the e5 pawn so this Bishop can
now move also Queen g5 or Queen g4
there's always Queen to f8 now to defend
checkmate so point to h4 and now now
Fischer doesn't really have the
opportunity to grab the c3 pawn now
because Queen h6 and the checkmate on g7
is unstoppable but he actually does have
the time to capture the c2 point but
again he doesn't go for this he plays h5
now Queen to g5 again having the option
of going Queen to h6 followed by g7
checkmate
so Knights the c4 Bishop captures pawn
captures and now rook to e3 we have
Queen to f8 rook to be one now rook to
b8
rook back to e1 rook captures rook
captures and now Bishop captures on c2
so Fischer manages to grab another pawn
and now it would be nice if he could
somehow somehow manage to push his bones
but all of some doesn't allow him he
plays rook to b7 we have Bishop to a5
and now comes Queen to e3
and now you don't really have the option
of stopping white from breaking your
Center if you try to hold on to
everything for example if you push efore
then your all of your phones are on
light squares you're never going to be
able to push d4 but that's the least of
your concerns as Queen to a7 actually
wins the game immediately for white
there's the turbo through our group to
b8 if you stop this with King to h7 then
rook captures f7 is a terrible threat
and lastly if you block this with Bishop
to c8
now you get rook to b8 with the threat
of Queen to 8th and if black plays now
King to h7 now I simply wrote captures
on CA
Queen captures and now Queen captures on
f7 if you go came to h8 then Queen to g7
is the immediate checkmate and if you
play King to h6 now you can win in a
whole lot of ways you can play Queen to
g7 check you can push h4 not allowing
the King to run away we are King to g5
so after stopping checkmate Queen - ahni
simply play Queen c7 and there is no
defense against pawn to f7 and point to
f8 so after the screen to eat remove
unfortunately you can't hang on to
everything Fischer played Bishop to e6
now Queen to a6 isn't the Queen to a7
isn't that terrible of a threat because
now you can play King age 70 f7 point is
protected by the bishop but now comes
the simple Queen captures on e5 so Queen
to a3 are grabbing another pawn and now
we have another critical position in the
game h3 is played here all of some
missed the opportunity to actually play
h4 and after this black is black is
doomed because it's very important to
stop stop this Jeep on from being pushed
to g5 because Fischer's main plan after
this h3 pawn was played was to play
Queen to c1 check and then push g5 if
you tried h4 then after Queen to c1 and
came to h2 you don't have g5 so you have
to play Queen to h6 and now after rook
to b8 check and King to h7 now you have
look to a8 and white that black doesn't
really have a move the threat you can't
move any of the pieces all the pawns are
locked if you play d4 you simply grab it
the Queen can't really move and have to
replay any move you get Queen to d8 and
there is no defense against Queen to h8
or Queen to g8 checkmate but all of them
missed this he played h3 instead of h4n
Fischer immediately seizes the
opportunity Queen to c1 check King h2
and now g5 so rook to a7 now h4
trying to lock that King on h2 and now
rook captures any ma6
getting rid of Fischer's passed pawn
king to h7 and now comes Luke to a one
with the
a sneaky idea of if Queen captures on a
wandering captors in g5 and you can't
stop queen g7 checkmate but okay Fischer
doesn't fall for this after okay one
Queen to f4 check Fischer exchanges
Queen's Queen captures G captures and
now rook to f1 and you can see that the
Fischer is still up upon but you can't
really defend a lot of the pawns so
there is no compensation for being the
exchange down Fischer played d4 we have
seek after somebody four and now King to
g6 rook captures on f4 now comes Bishop
to a5 blocking rooks protection of DF
six points of Fischer can capture it we
have rook to f3 King captures now rook
to e3 kinked g5 we have g3 Bishop to d3
and now d5 first play Bishop to f5 and
it was in this position after f5 Bishop
to a5 that Bobby Fischer resigned the
game why does he resign well there's the
there's that simple fact that you can't
really stop the D pawn from being
promoted to a queen you will have to
give up your bishop for example white
not simply pulls g4 after Bishop d7
rookie 7 attacking the bishop and the f7
pawn bishop moves now comes d6 after the
King attacks the rook to stop with the
point from being pushed now he pushed g5
with check and now it doesn't matter
what what black plays whatever black
plays he has to move away from the rook
either if he captures or he play
something like can get 5 now he simply
pulled d7 and the black has to capture
the pawn rook captures and after King
captures this pawn King rode captures
the f7 pawn and it's very simple you'll
simply get rid of this pawn I push the
King win this pawn and then when however
you prefer so yeah after this Bishop to
f5 more Fischer played it and then he
resigned the game this was move 45 so a
very nice game by both of them although
a lot of a lot of missed opportunities
in this game and you know both players
missed a lot of chances but it's very
interesting that motive of sacrificing
the rook on c3 a rook for a night that's
a but that's a really standard motive
and if you plug in someone who plays the
matter of you will more often than not
you will meet this move so it's a very
important for you to know when can you
expect it when it's good when it isn't
good so here was one example of when it
wasn't good and if Fischer did it one
move sooner then it you know it would
have been okay so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and you know I
know that if anyone woke you up at like
3 a.m. and asked you like a who won who
won second place in the 1959 candidates
tournament I'm sure you all would know
it was Paul Karras but you know for
those of you who may be new to this
channel and new to the 1959 candidates
tournament I will just show the final
standings as you can see Tull won the
tournament Paul Karason second-place
Petrosyan in third then Smith stole Liga
rich Fischer here in sixth olaf's on in
seven place and pal Benko unfortunately
for him in last place so here we can we
can check out this photo one more time
all the participants of the 1959
candidates tournament a very nice photo
like I said there will be a link in the
description below so you can you know do
whatever you want with it
and I would like to thank Gilmore Rowley
and William Avery for your continuous
contribution to this channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
I'm very glad that after all this time
you are still enjoying the content as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon